foreign
[Music]
here recently Kim Jong-un has lost a lot
of weight he looks great right right
but how did he do it several weeks ago I
received an anonymous tip that Kim Jong
had been smuggling his body secret into
the country
build bars
I suspect the deer leader was leaning
down with Bill bars when he began
showing signs of upper abdominal
definition and it was all but confirmed
when a closed Source gained access and
leaked his call logs
Dennis calm down trust me you bring the
pill pause I'll take care of costumes if
you don't hook me up I get fat again
you look amazing I'm so happy for you
and you're so happy okay okay so that's
four cases of double chocolate by two
cases of peanut butter brownie all right
hopefully I could get a deal or a case
the birthday cake
as far from me
can die three cases of the new chocolate
chip cookie dough
that was my favorite I know right how do
they make it
well there you have it it's clear that
we need a deep built bar eyes North
Korea before they become so powerful on
the global stage that it's too late
and the only way to do that is to order
it the entire world's supply of Bilt
bars
that's all for now whistleblower out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey look who it is and uh there's a
there's no sip no stuff going on today
because I don't want to contaminate so
I'm here but I'm not really fully here
down I was like down like 10 12 pounds
over the weekend on a diet uh yes it's
the Mexican tap water diet that's the
rotavirus that you get from a
one-year-old diet and uh I'm back up
four pounds in like the last eight hours
rehydrated but still I my thought
processing isn't there so uh actually
Gerald is going to be hosting we're just
going to mix it up a little bit here
today Dave is here jail is here but
we're going to switch everything and uh
let's let's uh well don't do that
Chinese fire drills
we have dragons I had no idea we had any
of that stuff wow well this is an
interesting location hi Dave
are you
you know I may have adjusted the chair
and I apologize for that on purpose
Everything feels off no no it's not
adjusted at all
I don't even to Imagine Dragons I just
saw them I didn't know we had that
effect the dancing panda bears were
banned that was awesome koalas Panda I
don't know it's a panda it's got to be
the panda I love it all right this is
different I like it pandas are useless
they are useless for breakfast Panda
cakes
you know when you said what do you need
for the show yeah not that what uh even
more all right well hey I get to do this
Dave welcome you're in you're in my spot
over there yes is it comfortable it is
uh a different view altogether it is
indeed I've actually never sat here yeah
well I can now see you on the show and I
don't know that that's a good thing I
will find out because I know you make
faces at me I do Stephen how are you
doing I know you were not well yeah I
was not well uh physically thank you the
people who Oklahoma who came out and I'm
sorry for sweating on you in the front
row uh it's like Gallagher oh my gosh it
was like I sweat on it but not like that
I was like something's wrong something's
wrong with me name that movie line so uh
and then I was just so sick like I can't
remember last time I took a sick day and
I just I'm like I literally can't keep
any liquid in me oh
too soon that's far too firm there
wasn't that much resistance
yes exactly no mine was making it mine
was a Steve mcqueening it
still it does as well
we've got the comedians with no chains
on whatsoever I apologize it's like
showing up at someone else's party and
just getting the lobby no it's been fun
right yeah this is what I get to do for
a living essentially here so I'm good
with it all right but thank you yeah my
thought processing was like I just it
was took everything I could to get up
this morning and I said let's put let's
put Gerald in and dress him like The
Polka Dot Door yes you know I asked you
several times about this shirt I know
you said every time I like it I love it
I lied every time no it looks good I
love and hate both isn't life so much
easier when you can just lie looks like
you're going on a blind date with a man
yes
that's about right I guess I'm still
good I am not still getting I have to
fight the soundboard from this chair
looks like someone could do this and
just pull it off in one swipe and the
glasses would still stay in your nipples
they would yeah I've done it I've tried
all right so uh today we're going to
talk about Biden on Jake Tapper last
night the interview was uh a huge
success for getting words out that makes
sense not really the military is going
to lay down the law and transgender uh
guys as well so that'll be a lot of fun
Troy Aikman I don't know I am the [ __ ]
well maybe not it's depending on which
way Troy Aikman is a bit of a sexist pig
apparently for making a very reasonable
sounding comment
um so we'll we'll see how that goes and
uh sudden mysterious and totally
unexplainable death while gaming we'll
get into that and see if we can possibly
get to this it's a mystery someone get
the lesbian scooby-dooers yes we have no
idea how that's gonna go and then for
mug Club we're gonna do Photoshop or not
but before we get to that Stephen
Crowder you and Dave Landau are on tour
Rebel with the cause Tour Nashville
November 12th at the Ryman Auditorium
second show 9 30 p.m still have some
tickets for that go to the website later
with crowder.com tour and also Baltimore
December 3rd yeah those are the only
ones with tickets left that's it so the
first show right Dave the first show at
Ryman is sold out yeah yes that's sold
out yes and the second one and I know
it's always tough because conservatives
you don't have uh jobs and so the later
shows but uh it's still like three
quarters three quarters full and by the
way uh David we want to make sure that
people know if you see tickets out there
for like 250 like 300 400 that's not us
people buy the tickets they scalp them
and they sell them it's me I'm sorry you
and your I just I should well you should
make fun of the shirts yeah yeah
it's StubHub and people grab them and
try to sell them they do 600 bucks do
they really oh yeah insane it's a real
problem you can do that wow so that's
not us but man did I did even some money
on the team in Oklahoma because uh
because what happened it was put
together last week there was one table
still available yeah and there was a
walk-in Dave and uh they walked out
after 20 minutes did they really
they didn't know what they were they
were not yet
they walked in what on what particular
Journey did they walk out on they walked
down the one where I was talking about
friendship Club where I have the
[ __ ] guy I used to counsel screaming
the n-word
they were both it was very successful
counseling they're both wearing Burger
King kids clubs
[Laughter]
gosh all right well Dave hey you're at
the uh the Funny Bone in Liberty Ohio
where's Liberty Liberty Township it's
between Dayton and Cincinnati it's right
in the middle okay
sandwich I lived in
most of Ohio is not a place you want to
be I lived there for four years actually
Cincinnati is great green it's very
beautiful that's not so bad near
Kentucky uh Cleveland not so much uh
Amherst uh also well Amherst isn't bad
at least the river's not enough that was
where Hot Dog Heaven was from what was
it Harold and Kamar yeah yeah it was in
Amherst in downtown yeah the real one
hot dog heaven that's an interesting
enough aside to delay the start of the
show all right absolutely so question of
the day
would you get a sex change to avoid
getting drafted from World War III that
was a bit of a pause just a mess with
Stephen sex change to win the UFC
Women's Championship well I don't think
we can and that's going to be the point
that we're going to talk about so
comment let us know what you think about
oh I already have it said would you Lop
it off no I already have it set up if I
do something that I you know there's no
coming back from how to say well I was I
was conflicted because I was secretly a
woman and then they'll say well no look
we saw you on your show all this time
that you said you were going to do this
I was like yeah that was that was me
that was a cry for help yeah this is a
cry for help we're deep inside I'm I'm
actually a woman and so I shouldn't be
drafted and I uh deserve to win the
female bantamweight title I'd probably
show up they just hand me pom-poms and
I'd go I'm not transgender and they'd go
we know we just yes we just need a
cheerleader
awesome all right well look we're going
to jump into the show uh and I know it's
it's hard to be accepted in today's
culture uh but this guy shows how to
live your best life
[Music]
geez what is that that's a poor choice
of songs too
forever
we've talked about statistics that might
actually happen I hope it doesn't just
saying okay he's a trucker is he the
first one was him driving a truck yeah I
didn't yeah
oh he's killed people yeah
tell him you like Pink Champagne man oh
that hair wig yeah that wig has a scalp
on it
can you play it again the music that he
picks
is that Mandy Moore that's Goo Goo Dolls
yeah
looks like a h but somebody else
it's still shocking oh
yeah and I don't want the world to see
me yeah that's fair we don't want you
yeah we don't want to see you either
that's a terrible song
for you uh not you yeah the light just
goes out
we'll run it was on a second ago six
we'll run the black light for you
absolutely well we're going to talk
about transgender in just a minute I
don't know if he's going full or if this
was just a little bit of fun for him on
the tick tockers you know area I have no
idea but we're going to get into it in a
minute but first before we do Joe Biden
sat down with Jake Tapper last night I
don't know if you guys caught it this
incredible one-on-one interview anytime
he sits down for a live interview it's
gonna produce some good material for us
and by good I mean completely horrible
for this country and the interview went
just as poorly as you would expect it
and that brings us to this week invite
nice if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black we we passed so much
legislation that significantly makes a
makes a point about you know the
American Rescue plan the legislation to
deal with inflation the the inflation
act we we passed the look what I ran on
I said we're going to deal with energy
look right and and the energy problem
we're going to deal with the whole
notion of global warming we passed 368
billion dollars worth of Health which as
the same Bankers talk about is going to
bring up billions a trillions 700
million dollar billion dollars off the
sidelines investment if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump and you ain't black most
important thing he's looking more and
more like Slappy from Goosebumps do you
see that with the two lines down is
except with the gray hair oh my gosh did
you hear what he said a million trillion
billionaire he's just went back and
forth well the sad part is was a
question about Russian nukes yes yeah
it's like Joe
um thanks Joe I didn't ask you about
that refer to the note card you dropped
that I picked up for you please yeah you
mean the cue card exactly because that's
about nukes he started talking about
RoboCop three yeah do you mean nuke drug
on the street great thing pink was it
three or two as I think that was two
yeah Sally's Diner yeah you sell it
right behind it yeah there's it right
there there's RoboCop it's not a joke oh
man well look I'm in that one I I'm
certainly
I'm certainly glad this guy is in charge
of the economy because inflation is up
more than expected yet again they
expected a an 8.4 percent increase in
PPA and it jumped to 8.5 but hey you
know who's counting at this point I
guess it just you know is draining the
life and that's the way they measure it
now if they use the same kind of metrics
as they used back when it was uh you
know like Jimmy Carter it would be well
I think people have said like 14 I don't
have that in front of me but yeah
they're great being very generous in
there they expected a 0.2 percent jump
and it jumped 0.4 kind of digging down
into the numbers and they're like well
that's not so bad it's up a hundred
percent more than you thought
it is as bad as it can possibly get I
think right now but don't worry 200 000
yeah 10 billion yeah I don't know 8.2
it's not a joke three percent oh my God
that's hilarious math
it's only the most you're funnier than
my tutor was well yeah yeah I had a
tutor who's like math can be funny he
said uh uh uh what's what's five your
sister he says what's five Q Plus 5q
it's like thank you he goes you're
welcome
oh no and then he said and then he said
just don't ask me what 2q plus 2q is
and I just kind of laughed like okay get
it he's like do you say it
and I was like 4q he's like hey hey this
is a family show like it's just you and
me in my kitchen
and that's when you were molested
[Laughter]
yeah count how many buckles are on your
belt I'm about to remove
that's one two three panels on my van
yeah you had this critical you keep yeah
it's even had the realization live on
air right now that guy was there for
other purposes and it had to do with
four and Q counted how many parents I
didn't tell oh my gosh all right so we
got to jump into this story because the
military as we've noted before is having
a really hard time going to woke and
trying to make sure that they get people
recruited and it's just when you take a
dump on yourself as the military it
makes it really hard but now they're
saying that transgenders do have to in
fact join the military right so it's
official if you were born a dude you
have to sign up for Selective Service
and uh that means draft right that's
draft yes for all those out there that's
when you sign a card that says hey if we
make a really bad decision and go to war
with somebody for whatever reason we
deem necessary or politically expedient
at time you gotta go except for women
except for women but they still got the
vote they said true they did get the
vote nobody not in the draft but yeah
you used to only have vote get the vote
if you were eligible for the draft and
then women like we want to vote we're
like okay you want to do the draft like
we don't want to do that we said you can
vote anyway yeah so you have to do
selective service if you select a cervix
[Laughter]
yeah I think it's just like a like an
inward Tremor oh it's I don't even know
it's down there
it's like the sound effects from Dune
yes a couple Mick Jaggers yeah
all right so look this isn't a new
policy or anything this has kind of been
in place for a while but the topic did
go viral when the U.S Selective Service
posted a tweet about who actually needs
to register and I'll read the quote for
you parents if your son is an only son
in the last male in your family to carry
the family name he is still required to
register with the and you should never
abbreviate with s's no it's just even if
you're using three for the SSS okay
let's just don't do that Selective
Service just say it it's okay they also
shouldn't have used lightning bolts
that's true you I know they were I know
they were big fans of Zeus but still you
shouldn't do it and this movie is saving
Saving Private Ryan would be like three
minutes long
you just hear the Germans from the
turrets so that's it that's all you
bring okay save your bullets oh we tried
then we just had lunch see what all
drowns I cannot swim
uh well look that tweet links to the
transgender section the one that we just
quoted uh of the SSS Bad Name website
where the official policy is listed
right so this is what people are
clicking on U.S citizens are immigrants
who are born male and changed their
gender to female are still required to
register individuals who are born female
and change their gender to male are not
required to register comment below do
you think that's fair if you were born a
woman and you add on the the requisite
materials or not and just take off the
ones that you know we don't have you
don't have to join the bags look it begs
the question why yeah they they don't
believe they're [ __ ] no they just
not like if you're female to male it's
but you're absolutely 100 you have all
the shared experiences you are now uh
completely uh a man right you now exist
through all all the experience that has
made all the Privileges but you no of
course we don't expect you to be as
physically capable you you don't need to
be eligible for Selective Service it
look either be 100 on one side or the
other you can't consistently have it
both ways they don't believe it no and
and what's really funny is that people
now in the transgender Community thank
you are aren't happy about the news at
all and so this is pretty funny a
headline in pink news by the way if you
didn't know a gay publication what
a headline read trans women every
balloon not Herald yes
I read three in the stink yes
uh plane Drifter
Brown starfish post
all the News That's fit to pound
[Laughter]
anyway that's one brown eye times
[Laughter]
seems a bit on the nose as a name for
your publication lesbian
it would be normal in Babylon they're
good well the quote read trans women
must sign up for the USB
damn you
foreign
I have more but I'm trying to figure out
what's going to get us ripped off the
internet oh there's a lot you don't
think you don't think the SS trans
Brigade is gonna do it yeah well that's
true yeah I'm just very curious I think
personally well we're on a serious topic
if you're gonna put on the dong
it's just probably worse than any pun I
was gonna make you should probably go
and uh fight yes yes or subscribe to the
pink news yes that's what I do just
doesn't make a lot of sense to me anyway
here's the quote from said you can't
join the outfit no
drop down and give me head
[ __ ] what we have here
you're about to call me an [ __ ] that
was the quote from earlier
listen we're gonna get through this pink
news trans women must sign up for the US
military draft under irrational and
outside stack dicks that happened
came out like officer gentlemen Love
dickass Shop Where We Belong
I will cut off your balls so that you
cannot fight in any of my Wars private
good it wouldn't be the first one was
like already done it just fly in live
live
we're so bad
um the article also concluded or
included sorry some scathing responses
by Trend activists on Twitter they were
not very happy about this F The
Selective Service System and it's
transphobic bio essentialist inclusion
of trans women as men I don't know why
an accent is necessary to read that it
just seems irrational so I did it
another user lamented on their status as
a trans person and this one this is
where it really starts to hit home guys
really this is a serious moment being
home where their dad hasn't been in nine
years that's true
probably longer
being trans isn't fun anymore
please sound like that any
body
you're just taking all the fun out of it
guys oh that's hilarious being trans
isn't fun anymore either is life I just
got my Selective Service letter they're
going to put me in the trenches those
are called early Graves yeah that's they
don't use trenches anymore
because it's about fun yeah it's been a
better I don't know about a hundred
years since we did Trent's Warfare I
mean maybe there's a trench here or
there you know for some cover but it's
not like that's what we normally do yeah
and do us a favor hit the like button
and absolutely screws you like to do
that [ __ ] hole
[Laughter]
we'll do yeah
[Laughter]
I'd like to share a glory hole with you
anytime yes
you can be in my hole oh what whoa no no
don't sound like that no come on context
matters
none of them are fighting but they are
all hiding behind
it's a camaraderie Dave Band of brothel
they don't even bring guns
there's immediately abandon their post
it's like it's like Homeward tit down no
no no no no no no no no no run away well
all of this is interesting because then
we had a bit of a different reaction
when uh the Donald Trump banned trans
people from joining the military watch
you know what do you want not just the
president but others out there to know
about your service your commitment to
this country
right I I can't think of a single person
that decides to join the Army or the
military any branch of service on a whim
we all want to do something that is much
larger than ourselves and contribute in
a way and are extremely patriotic and
hard-working people you know and to to
think of people judging us by happening
to be transgender and that shouldn't
make any difference on our ability to
serve and it doesn't make any difference
on our ability to serve we all carry out
our jobs and do our duties every single
day and this isn't going to stop me from
continuing to show up continuing to do
my job I have never missed a training as
a result of being transgender this
hasn't impacted my ability to serve and
I've fulfilled my obligations over the
last 12 years well Captain Robertson
apparently the Selective Service agrees
with you that opinion's not very old by
the way what is the key requirements did
Captain Robertson have to go through do
we know do we know which way Captain
Robertson when I can't well either way
you know do you guess I think Captain
Robertson wasn't a woman to man isn't
that the whole thing yeah biological
female born and so did you have to do
did Captain Robertson have to do the
female teacher well now they have the
gender neutral right so they all have to
do the same thing and then they still
fail because the other ones were it was
just too hard because that's how combat
is rated we prepared for combat by doing
things that aren't very hard it's not
fun anymore well it's definitely not fun
to be transgender anymore
serving as a country though with pride
yes that's admirable regardless right
absolutely but the the problem is it
doesn't matter which way this goes right
they're going to be pissed off and use
the victim card right now we talked
about this the other day when we played
the Family Guy clip it's like oh yes
just please do whatever you want all the
time you know it's like complain however
you want all the time but look luckily
for all the trans Patriots Biden
overturned Trump's ban shortly after
taking office
and what I'm doing is enabling all
qualified Americans to serve their
country you voted for it you did this is
what you wanted the fascist is gone
restoring the situations against before
were transgender Personnel if qualified
in every other way can serve their
government in the United States military
absolutely well this was the guy you
voted for you can't have it both ways
either you're pissed off because you're
banned from joining the military or
you're happy that you can go and join
the military if you want but look if you
were born a man Slappy's Revenge part
part of being a man is selective service
this is something that we've talked
about right there are responsibilities
that men are born with and we understand
that and we gladly take on those
responsibilities as long as you don't
crap on us for having those
responsibilities and the personalities
to fulfill them never in my wildest
dreams if you'd have asked us 10 years
ago would we imagine a president wearing
a mask signing a bill that people who
only three months ago who lived their
entire life as a man can now identify as
women enjoy them military that way and
you know what here's the thing it's the
same issue we've talked about we've had
sergeants on the show you know who are
Anonymous female sergeants it's uh it
changes the dynamic you know in in a in
a troop yeah uh when you have a woman in
there because men want to protect women
they don't want them to be harmed right
so they often this idea you never leave
someone behind that's not true with
women they'll be more protective they
actually might actually they might
actually stay behind and also when
you're dealing with look the statistics
show that with transgender individuals
the the litigation is off the charts I
mean how many times have we had to deal
with it this is going to create an
uncomfortable environment where people
are walking on eggshells you should not
have to worry about
offending people because you're not
using the right pronouns when you are
right the heat of battle and the people
who are saying this isn't fair it's not
fun anymore those are the exact kind of
people who are going to go in looking to
be offended what you want are
leather-necked Hillbillies who would be
killing something any exactly you want
people who want to be in there fighting
there's there's a reason that warriors
were venerated throughout history of
course and now now we're trying to force
this is what happens when you try and
force the people who have no business
being Warriors to be Warriors they then
complain that they might actually be
thrust into a warrior role No it should
all be Performance Based and if you're
if you're a female identifying as a male
and you can make it through all the male
uh requirements goodbye yeah absolutely
I mean that's fine but sure well you
don't want to change the culture of the
military in this kind of way and I know
people use it well what about when they
allow black people that was that's a
totally different thing what I'm saying
is you don't want to make the military
less effective by the training that you
require because you're making allowances
for people that you shouldn't be making
it's the standard is the standard it
doesn't matter who you are yeah I don't
care if if you're the most fit person
out there if you can't pass the standard
to go into battle and fight for this
country and make sure that we win the
war you don't get to go it's an
incredibly lazy argument let me show you
that sort of lazy argument the same
thing when they say interracial marriage
you know and compared to same-sex
marriage let me ask you this do you
believe for a second that when you're
talking about uh uh men let's just let's
just use men for as an example men in
the battlefield do you believe that
there is something that a white man and
I'm no no no joking here we want to be
careful yeah uh that there's something
that a white man brings to the
battlefield that a black man can't no no
I of course I don't do you believe
there's something that'll that a white
man or black man or brown man or pick
whatever color you want here brings to
that service that a woman can't
yes they're not fundamentally energy men
and women are not interchangeable as men
of different colors interchangeable just
as women of different colors are largely
interchangeable right largely not we
have differences of course there are
differences between races but we are
fundamentally the same if we are men if
we are males and if we are women to act
as though it's comparable to act as
though Two Dads is the same as a mom and
a dad whether it's black or white a mom
and a dad is doesn't matter the race
doesn't matter but a child needs a dad
yeah if a child only has two moms he's
missing a dad yeah but child only has
two dads he's messing him up if you have
a brigade and all of a sudden you have
one second it's not just mixed rate it's
it's trans that that is fundamentally
different from people of different races
it is a racist argument to make yeah
because you were suggesting that black
and white is as different as male to
female transgender soldiers which by the
way they don't even believe because they
told you it's no longer to be fun yeah
exactly because it's a minority type
where you're comparing a minority's skin
color between the sex and it just
doesn't make sense it's not no it like
you said it's a very lazy art Jesus
easily defeated and actually is a little
bit racist I just want our military to
be good at fighting I believe men and
women are very different I don't believe
that biologically white men and black
men are that different I think there are
some differences and they can fly just
fine black men are faster they well they
may have some advantages yes check every
oh where could I possibly everyone got
quiet where can I possible all of the
top 20 land speed records exactly find a
single white guy for crying out loud I'm
just saying there are different
attributes that people from different
races may have but they're not that
different I don't believe it it's
happening along yes you said that
actually I was like I've watched
professional sports
[Laughter]
if you we want to put out an all-white
basketball team or football team versus
all black one and go which one you want
to bet on Dave I'm not going to go oh
the honkies is it Larry Bird then
definitely the other guy he's 5 000 on
the crackers and I won't be back to get
my money right
simply with boxing unless the white
guy's Irish and he's currently drunk yes
well look well and I think he made a
good point though Joe it really is about
the complaining is it it's no matter
what they do you got what you wanted now
it's okay exactly so it doesn't really
matter what anybody does to cater to
anyone or to help fix the situation or
give them what they want because all of
a sudden you don't want it exactly all
about being a protected class and and
complaining about never getting your way
even when you get it yes right so just
pick a lane for us and let us know just
tell everyone else what you want but you
got to pick a lane guys all right it's
time to move on this is a live show
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m ish
Eastern Rumble podcast wherever you
listen to them and also subscribe to mug
club we would like nothing more than
everybody to go over to rumble so that
we don't have to deal with these issues
with YouTube we could speak with just a
little bit more freely yeah
Gerald's Gerald's really holding it
together pretty well and don't be a shot
at toss your points in there you're
going a little bit by uh by the map you
don't have to I know I'm leaving room
for the comedians to do the thing I
think people are getting a big laugh
today because you guys don't have to
like carry parts of the serious subject
yeah I know I get to be the youth pastor
look which I told you before the show
and you're like no no you're killing it
kid just wear that you're gonna make us
play some game where we have to drink
through the next guy's sock or something
all right guys no that's a terrible I
don't know what church you went to so
you had a tutor that wanted to have you
say fork you out loud to him so no he
wanted to Fork me well that too and then
you went to a church where he's like hey
drink out of this suck yeah that's what
they do they give you a Coke that's so
stupid well it was Pepsi can it was
actually it was for those who think
President's Choice and uh they made us
drink they're like the next guy the next
guy you're gonna have to drink your coke
through his sock like no see that's
because you don't trust where he's been
then you're like so that's what happens
when you're having sex with somebody
stepping on pumpkins with those skis and
only fans we're gonna close the blinds
if you notice the windows and the doors
are locked from the outside yes
back to bad places to go that's my point
yep so so we're gonna get into something
that I know Steven really enjoys talking
about Troy Aikman you guys remember him
yes Super Bowl wedding quarterback for
the Dallas who's your Super Bowl winning
quarterback for the Detroit Lions I
always forget the guy's name his name is
is uh who might as well be me I don't
know if he's been born yet we'll see the
future is promising Dave because we
can't see it it wasn't for the Detroit
Lions but we do Matthew Stafford did go
to another team the year after and won a
Super Bowl it should make every Detroit
Lions fan feel fantastic yeah so we did
have the capability on the team for a
long time that's at least good to know
well look Dallas Cowboys Hall of Famer
Troy Aikman is in hot water over some
extremely sexist comments that he made
during Monday Night Football
and that may that brings us to this
edition of I no Sports oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I don't know if you guys saw
uh any of this but there was a bit of
criticism over the call during the
Raiders Chiefs game when pass
interference has just been this really
stupid penalty on quarterbacks this year
uh because they're trying to protect the
quarterbacks a little bit but it seems
like they're going a little bit too far
but that's not really what Aikman got in
trouble for he got in trouble for his
comment on this and wasn't saying that
he didn't like the the way that they
called the flat or the penalties on this
it just he said something that maybe uh
maybe some people took the the wrong way
but you can see it right here here we go
he's there it's just where it is too
much I mean My Hope Is the competition
committee looks at this next
set of meetings and
you know we take the dresses off oh
oh
and they joined the army well look
eggman's not exactly
exactly he's not exactly wrong right the
NFL is getting kind of soft but let's
look at the playing question again I
just want to go through this with you
for for one second Steve so so you see
the defensive end right there he gets
past the tackle that's poor technique
pulls him down boom goes around him a
330 pound guy he actually sacks the
quarterback he's also stripping the ball
out Stephen you see that that's a hate
crime what do you think of the the
technique there well I think it's a hate
crime and I also is it that's a there's
a penalty for that there is a penalty
why is there a penalty for that he's
hitting that guy and he doesn't land on
him full this guy goes out of his way
not to put all of his 300 and well
that's a lot of weight too well they've
also taken all the fun out of out of
football hold on a second can you can
you back to just the end of that clip
why is what hold on do you know who that
is yeah no hold on
okay that happens making a point here
though well Han what's and then why is
the McDonald's drive-through guy yes
I ordered fries I don't care
but I also understand I don't understand
like why is that a penalty because
Donald McDonald's yeah
in yard roughing the pass or penalty
because we might need to admonish you oh
why uh what did I say you you said Chris
Jones is a defensive end I didn't say
Chris Jones
but you were describing Christian the
guy that was it was a defensive end that
came around the tackle
don't you dare I'm not could be a
Defender he could be a linebacker he was
lined up as a de there I don't know
about right now they're saying it's
Chris Jones the defensive tackle oh shut
up this shows how much you know about
sports defensive tackles can move out
and play the end position Micah Parsons
the linebacker plays the defensive end
position on certain plays he went around
a tackle therefore it's a defensive end
I do know Sports by the way the reason
that that's a penalty hold on
yeah my stomach is hurting I'm having to
defend mine
when we talk about sports Stephen gets
physically ill no no I'm gonna when we
go to YouTube uh when we go to my club I
know you're being serious I'm going to
take a break
admonish admonish the token now she was
wrong admonish those who admire right
don't we agree Dave yeah I agree I think
they were wrong he's technically a
defensive tackle who is in the end
position come on Gerald knows these
Sports he blew out his knee devoted his
life to It Gerald just owned that my
position was tight end I know these
things yeah that doesn't sound gay
I have a huge boner right now
you know
you all left me hanging on that one and
now it just looks like a cling drill
being an idiot you know that thanks a
lot the camera on me so there's no way
the audience doesn't know you didn't
just
and then I have to argue with myself I
don't
know why that's not allowed all right so
they're protecting quarterbacks by the
way Derek Carr the guy that he sacked
the the quarterback for Los and Los
Angeles sorry Las Vegas Raiders gets
paid 40.5 million dollars per year you
think he could take a tackle right but
they're the owners are saying we don't
want that investment to get hurt so we
need to make sure that we don't allow
These Guys these serial killers that
have found a creative Outlet called
defensive ends to kill our quarterbacks
when they go in 330 pounds you can't
just stop that like what are you
supposed to do two-handed touch I don't
understand what's wrong with that I
really don't when I said he hit him I
play football in like like uh up to like
Junior High and we won provincials we
won a provincial game like 60 something
to nothing you must be so proud of
yourself but things I didn't even know
the rules yeah so all I knew was like if
you grabbed that was illegal so you
couldn't grab so I was like well how do
I stop someone if I can't grab them they
said just Ram your head into them and I
was like oh that doesn't seem prudent
you ever heard of CTE Canada
I have no idea why that's illegal so
they're they're trying like there's some
old footage so uh token Island there's a
there's a play where Tom Brady gets his
helmet blown off yeah like earlier on in
his career he gets hit like you could
pull up have them pull up some like
clips of what quarterbacks used to get
hit like I'm not talking about like in
the 60s and 70s go back to like the late
90s early 2000s and you'll find some
really really great like they would get
pummeled but now they're like oh we're
investing too much in these guys and so
we want to make sure that they don't get
injured on the field and so it sisifies
the game and in this case it potentially
changes the outcome of a game right it
could be third down and long you get a
penalty like that it's an automatic
first down the defense wins because that
guy stripped the ball out before he got
he was down and now it's a penalty I
have a genuine question here could it
because uh they did this with hockey and
they've done this somewhat with boxing
and trying to make it safer are there
unintended consequences that make it
more dangerous for example in hockey
they they change rules a lot to speed up
the game right so what happened now is
you actually have more open Ice hits the
game is a lot faster right and so I
think Sydney Crosby had more concussions
in one season then Wayne Gretzky had his
whole career because they also don't
have the enforcers and the same with
boxing if you go back and you watch like
Joe Frazier fights or you go back and
watch Joe Lewis they would clinch up
right that was they would talk about
fighting on the inside whereas if you go
and watch newer fights they separate
them a lot more because they're going oh
we don't want any rabbit punches but
what that's done is keep them at range
more and so they're getting more full
force strikes right as opposed to kind
of working the body and so it's actually
they're saying more blunt force trauma
to the brain because of the rules that
they created to make it safer is there
something like that that could be
happening so it's not really happening
where they're losing or they're getting
more injuries right so the natural
thought is okay if they're being softer
on one guy they're doing something to
slow themselves down and maybe that
leads to potential injuries so far that
hasn't happened so far what it has done
is protected the quarterbacks but this
is a part of the game the goal is to hit
the guy with the ball as hard as you can
and knock the ball out so that you can
get it and have a turnover right so
that's the whole point and when you're
rushing the password these guys are
coming at Angles these are very very big
fast strong men who have a hard time
slowing down down at 330 pounds running
that fast especially when you're still
trying to get to the quarterback like
what are you supposed to do just kind of
like make sure you don't go too hard
like they're already falling off did you
see his left hand by the way his left
hand went to the ground instead you know
what they used to do you would put all
of your weight on the quarterback and
intentionally make sure nothing else hit
the ground so that you 330 pound pancake
that guy that was the goal that's fine
and now they're sissifying the game well
look well your goal is to injure them
yeah even if it was well the Saints got
in trouble for that there was a bounty
on them going out and injuring the
coaches were paying bonuses if they
injured opposing players yes that's that
was like four years ago maybe five I
can't remember exactly when so not long
ago that was the deal you can't bring a
knife out but you need yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly I've got that I've got that
Brady clip but also
defensive tackle Christian I already
told you why that's wrong mic drop I
already told you you're the mic just hit
you in the force Harold's in the spirit
of the law and token Owens on the letter
of the law I have to say I give Gerald
crap I go with Gerald on this thank you
I gotta I got to go I appreciate that
let's let's see the uh Tom Brady I have
to go with the Polka Dot Door
oh oh oh oh oh there's oh my God yeah
his helmet went flying his head's still
there don't worry hey you know what
actually for Mud Club the QB sneak
[Laughter]
we have to bring up guys bring up on mug
Club the Dean Kane highlight reel oh
yeah he was a tackle or is he defensive
he set some sacking records he may have
been at safety but he was unbelievable
he just threw his because he was smaller
he was through his hole it's like a
missile he just yeah his whole body
which he's paid for it but okay sorry no
no no no you're fine so comment on this
let me know what you think is the NFL
screwing up the game by having way too
many and the thing happened with Tom
Brady as well it actually did change the
outcome of the game they were actually
stopping them they got a penalty for no
reason whatsoever but the funny part of
this story is that the feminist blue
check marks weren't happy about Aikman's
comment at all and sports reporter and
prominent lesbian I didn't know there
was a prominent lesbian category but
okay Ariel or suto tweeted in full
agreement that the call against Chris
Jones was BS but did Troy Aikman just
say that he hopes the competition
committee takes off their takes their
dresses off as in trying to demean them
by calling them women is he actually
serious yes he is hey what happened you
know no vagina no opinion how many Downs
of football do you think that broad's
played yeah yeah no penis no football no
opinion yeah also how many hours later
did she tweet that after her boyfriend
told her about it yeah wait she's a
lesbian oh sorry so she had maybe I
don't want to see female Sports
reporters unless it's through a hole in
the dressing room well maybe she's the
butch in the relationship and therefore
a fan of football yeah let's just be
glad Troy Aikman isn't jumping over a
fence and killing his ex-wife in a
waiter yes
I sure do you think he's not punching
her in an elevator yeah
I have a checkered past I did stock his
seller one time no joke really not a
joke
absolutely and Fortune Magazine
editorial director Rachel
almost said the other one dozel yeah
Lobdell lamented a truly awful call but
let's not Overlook Troy Aikman's sexist
comment my hope is the competition
committee looks at this in the next set
of meetings and we take the dresses off
boy would I love to see those broads in
uh like an NBA locker room with black
guys and just the crap they talk to each
other oh man which we all know I mean
it's just it's hysterical if you played
football if you played any sport yeah
were you being you know I mean it's a
part of the culture right the traffic
one of these days those balls are going
to drop right yeah you'd think they'd
say like hey take off your dress
yeah I think that's how mild it would be
no they just all the dogs hanging out
like never-ending breadsticks
[Laughter]
some bread sticks are longer than others
yeah
they just feel assaulted yeah well you
guys know that wide receiver the picture
of me right where it's obviously nice of
a female reporter no no no no it's a
it's a guy named Bobby Brown and it's
like that's my photo credit because I'm
like in the background but they thought
this jersey was 89. um he did tell me
one time I was sitting getting treatment
and I didn't have my shirt on he goes
you know we have a weight room right
yeah
that's about as mild as it got
soul crushing stuff yeah shoes would do
that too yeah I had to do and like I
played for all of the day but it's like
I had to do a roach you know the roach
Thrills where you charge it yeah yeah
yeah a kid who was 300 pounds yeah at
that time I think I was 83 pounds yeah
I went flying and my helmet fell off oh
yeah but concussion probably but nobody
cared at that point no it was
deliberately to hurt you but it's the
stuff that you say in a locker room it's
like that's just what it's it's part of
sports
we used to say they used to say uh you
know like with Donald Trump or that
quote they used to say if someone says
I'm gonna probably go you know this
isn't the locker room yeah and now
they're like you know the locker room
isn't the place for this it's like well
they're they're quite literally and then
you wonder why men say there are no men
no men's only spaces yeah the locker
room or in sports for criminal the stuff
that my coaches said to me you should
hear the stuff my dad when he played he
played hockey you know insulting your
ancestry oh of course it's like
they've been dead for 25 years why are
you bringing them up I mean you say such
horrible things in sports that you
literally have to uh Andy Kaufman where
you're just a character like when I
insult your mom it's not your mom your
mom's lovely wait right but the things
I've said about your mom and my mother
as a separate person are just
unspeakable they're unforgivable but
it's because it's not your mom that's
what you do in sports
well I got into a fight on the field
with Rocky boyman and he was a defensive
end not a defensive tackle to Okinawan
and we got into a fight because our
helmet stuck together there was a little
U at the top sometimes when with the the
face mask and it just got wedged on him
and so neither one of us could really
move because if you do you just move the
other person right they call it and he
started hitting my head to knock the
helmet out like as hard as he could yeah
and I shoved him and we got into a fight
and then in the locker room we were like
yeah man hey sorry about that yeah like
we got it out of our systems that's what
guys do if you give us room for that
then we do that if you don't if you if
you separate us too long then you hold a
grudge against somebody and then you
knife them in the parking I wonder if we
could bring in uh Pop's Crowder from mug
Club I know he's not feeling very well
out there but he has a story pops
Crowder about the uh when you played
hockey with your brother he played older
League because he was he was better yeah
and the guy said something about his cup
in the uh in the locker room his doniger
no no about his actual cup let's see if
pops Crowder can just come in and I
would love to tell that story all right
yeah well look not one the one Dad where
the on the Water Front reference okay
nice well not wanting to see him sex is
Troy Aikman did go ahead and clarify and
responded on ESPN
well that clarifies it this has been I
know Sports
[Applause]
[Music]
all right if you are that 80 pound
weakling and you would like to get
stronger we've talked about this all the
time you don't necessarily need to have
a protein bar but these things are
fantastic so if you're looking to get
more protein this is a good way to do it
go to built.com and use promo code
crowder15 to get 15 off your next order
you eat them as dessert I'm so glad I
didn't bring them with me I usually
bring them with me on the road but out
yeah and the last few things that I ate
I'll never eat again you send a text
message to the team like hey guys um I
said remove mind removing all of the
things that I saw right before
everything every single Rockstar Energy
Drink and I get these overnight oats
from Trader Joe's and I'll never drink
bourbon again
people who I in the wine business if you
get drunk and you end up having a really
bad night and you you know uh evacuate
and you see the seaweed salad again that
you just ate you never eaten seaweed
salad again it's just not happening no
there's certain things I can't eat there
was something in Canada called nectar
which was like a honey soda I could
never Canadians you guys can comment
below I can never touch it again because
I I remember it was Canadian
Thanksgiving and I couldn't eat
Thanksgiving dinner for 15 years really
yeah they call that Southern Comfort
Tanqueray Aftershock gold Slugger
purple drink peach schnapps MD 2020.
Dave's listing all of the things he
would have to clear out all those nights
you've had with every terrible drink and
you wake up you're like I'll never drink
that again because it was the booze's
fault yeah
I wasn't well Casey and it wasn't I
wasn't really drunk or anything no no
when you have the stomach flu the last
thing like it just turns my stomach so
I'm really actually glad because I can
still I usually have built bars with me
always on the road and I just I ran out
so I'm like thank God we'd have to
change sponsors yeah I know like A
Clockwork Orange yeah like no no change
the song
all right well a few weeks ago we we let
you know that there was this sudden case
of Falling Down syndrome is what we'll
call it and we had a compilation of that
but look it's not just for athletes
anymore a study published on Monday
October 10th reported that video gaming
Dave I know you're a big gamer yeah it
can trigger deadly heart problems in
children right and this is this is a
little bit strange
um I I know I've heard stories before
about people doing like these Extreme
Gaming sessions for 18 to 20 or 24 hours
or something like that and dying but
it's usually like this China yeah yeah
exactly like it's usually this really
large fellow
um who's doing this in his mom's
basement covered in Cheetos so that's
the kind of person have you seen the
energy drinks now do they now have four
Gamers it's like 400 milligrams of
caffeine and I can't do that stuff your
heart's just gonna one day explode there
could be other reasons we'll figure that
out but the study population that
they're talking about here
um was 22 patients total right so it's
not like a huge sample size but 86
percent of them were young males six had
cardiac arrest and four suddenly died
that's a pretty high number four out of
22 these are all Gamers yes this is from
the study
right so the study author Claire Lawley
said video games may represent a serious
risk to some children with a rhythmic
conditions that's a heart issue it's the
game's fault yeah it's totally the
game's fault for making your bad heart
tick a little too fast they might be
lethal they stick fast when I play
Leisure Suit Larry and uh those uh
ladies of the night no your heart is
beat fast you looked at She-Hulk cards
or Duke Duke Nukem you all know what I'm
talking about yeah you're more of a cami
Street Fighter fan aren't you yeah yeah
to continue the quote they might be
lethal in patients with predisposing but
often previously unrecognized rhythmic
conditions right not sure why we're
asking you to hit the like button here
if you like pre-existing conditions
killing you while you're gaming then
please hit our like button if you've had
a cardiac arrest while playing games hit
the like button if you too but wait
there's more syncope a sudden loss of
consciousness from heart problems has
also been a focus for research for
several years Dr a lot of the same
person the study author has researched
gaming and heart problems as far back as
September 2019 and the study conclusion
from the original study I'll quote
electronic gaming can precipitate lethal
cardiac arrhythmias in susceptible
children right all right so that all
sounds good the guy conduct this was the
Oliver Twist well this is well her her
her name Dr Claire Lolly please sir can
I game some more that's true I did a
male voice this is why I don't do voices
so much thank you Steven yo Play You'll
Play quake and you'll lock it mess yes
Doom for the Doom fan it's it's if you
don't finish your golden eye you won't
get your Call of Duty I was really good
at Golden I was playing pong and I [ __ ]
my pants and keeled over yeah
yeah it's 1979 right yeah yeah it
happened in my grandmother it was
playing pong yeah I watched her die
it's not that's not true didn't happen
now but I was told to say it or the
government would hurt me you're lying
and then they took they took it to the
emergency room with two ambulances going
like but then the girl and just gone
back and forth between them down the
streets like this and then there were
ghosts trying to eat the ambulance
those were Muslims in burkas mate Oh I
thought they were good those were
Burgers Muslims make you eat the Halal
they change colors you can take care of
them
they didn't they didn't care for the
fruit oh my gosh well look now I
remember remember
old pack yeah used to beat your [ __ ] out
of his broad head little pink BOGO
flying yeah yeah he's got a pink bow on
his head now though I guess he's lost it
a bit he stole it from her you can't
tell Pac-Man from Miss Pac-Man yeah no
no no it's all the same these days it's
just one bow yeah that's it and you can
hardly tell yes penis bulge somewhere
down left oh so just put a little effort
in there you just you just put on a bow
that's all it is there yeah I know it's
you
now look who exactly are the people who
might be more susceptible to cardiac
arrhythmia
[Music]
you can't get me [ __ ] I'm boosted yeah
boosted
oh my God
oh God
the hell out of here this is my Lobby
[ __ ] I got a big dick looking at your
mom like what
[Music]
wow they they take that stuff seriously
at an early age
nine-year-old it sounds like oh my gosh
now
I don't we're not saying that there's
any connection
between arrhythmias and the vaccine
never say that or boosters or any shots
that you could possibly ever get into
your body at any time of course not
right just referring to the chair that I
put in here that's that's true oh the
booster chair yes yes ah yeah yes did I
ask for a big boy do you imagine talking
smack to somebody who literally just
died on the other end and you just don't
know it yet and you're like
I oh
yeah you lose oh hey yeah Johnny
actually just did die why are you quiet
oh oh you do all you doing is silent
treatment all right all right I see how
it is see how it is oh you want to play
huh now you guys not even gonna play
this is a little passive talk to me come
on it's passive aggressive
hey all right you know what all right
you know you made your point you're
making me paranoid all right now you
made your point let's get back to you
win okay that's yeah I took it a little
too far I mean that's my bad are you up
are you all right you dumb you dumb
[ __ ]
you gotta come down off that guy and
you're like oh okay I need to walk this
back yeah being concerned but still
calling him every name yeah yeah exactly
you know you're a bastard right yeah
look I I know take your dress off he did
he may have playing with Troy Aikman
yeah yeah
put put this on he just drops a dress
You Gonna Act Like a [ __ ] I'm gonna you
still gonna look like a [ __ ] here's a
health pack
drop it for you look and though we're
not saying that there's any connection
100 clear that we would never say that
there's any connection according to the
Florida Surgeon General Dr Joseph let up
ladopo latapo
sounds like an antidepressant this
alanisis for you found there it's an 84
increase in the relative incidence of
cardiac related death among males 18 to
39 year olds with 28 within 28 days
following the MRNA vaccine I just want
to say it too loud no no this is what
this is what the Surgeon General of
floor percentage what percent said 84
that's uh that seems 84 increase wow 84
increase in the relative incidence of
cardiac related death among males 18 to
39 years
old within 28 days following mRNA that's
a lot of percent that's not many days
after the thing he said it
well I mean that's a common age for a
massive heart attack while playing video
games yeah why are we taking the words
from a uh a quack he's a he's a Surgeon
General like does that even like do you
get voted in for that quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack
Disco Duck
all right look for releasing this
information to the public doctor
no no no worse worse Dave he's been
blocked over Twitter for several hours
also during an evening
[Laughter]
tell the truth again I will never speak
in my official capacity as a doctor and
the head of a state let's get fictitious
zip it this is why your 40 years of
college and three million yeah yeah
so Twitter can say I disagree with you
okay a blue-haired lesbian yeah yes she
knows more yeah the one who complains
about Troy Aikman's comments yeah let
them know all the references hmm
all the references are Vader available
at ladder with crowder.com you can go
there you can check out all of this
stuff we're not making this stuff up
we're showing you what these people are
saying this next part is especially
troubling uh because during the EU
Parliament hearing a a Pfizer executive
admitted their vaccine was never tested
for doing something that they said 100
that's what we were told that it would
help reduce transmission oh no plus the
Pfizer covet vaccine tested on stopping
the transmission of the virus before it
entered the market
if not please say it clearly if yes are
you willing to share the data with this
committee and I really want straight
answer yes or no and I'm looking forward
to it thank you very much
regarding the question around
um did we know about stop and
humanization before it's entered the
market no these
um you know we had to really move at the
speed of science to really understand
what is taking place in the market
that's not a speed uh yeah I'm sorry the
speed of what no is this a new Coldplay
song
said seriously did we just hear the
speed of science
Chris Martin's a doctor now
[ __ ] the speed of zero
responsibility we were moving too
quickly oh you think we could have asked
that question earlier on wait a minute
we did say that hey this is coming out
pretty quickly not that we would say
that there's anything wrong with what
you ended up producing it's totally fine
even though you're laughing saying of
course we didn't test it for
transmissibility we didn't have time
they called it operation warp speed not
slow down and make sure you do it right
speed operation science
though you did a great job this says
ludicrous speed right
you never go to ludicrous speed and
remember that lady answering the
question she's gone plain Yeah well yeah
they're like you're not supposed to
reveal that she's John Candy's character
yeah it's the most candid answer we've
gotten so far well look we've covered
before you remember the study in uh 2022
that followed 200 000 patients and found
no increase in myocarditis after code
infection so no increase because of the
infection itself right
yeah right A lot of people say well
covet is having this effect on people
it's long covet or it's the effects from
covet after you get it and children 18
to 39 are young men 18 to 39 are just
the increase is because of that well we
also saw in the UK The increased deaths
it was up a staggering percentage in
August just a month or just July or
August was 17 incredible not year month
over months of bodies yeah yeah not in a
year just month over month right excess
deaths and we're going to see more of
these things coming out too I think just
as time goes on we asked this question
do you think information will come out
well if people are as stupidly honest as
this yes right if they feel like they
have no they don't they don't fear
repercussion at all right they have no
liability whatsoever and no
accountability of course they're going
to come out in and I'm not kidding she
laughingly said that right there was a
kind of a laugh in her voice and she's
like well no we couldn't do that duh
like that's more hopefully more of that
comes out yeah Piers Morgan just tweeted
about because of that it's like yeah see
I'm so happy because you guys are idiots
it's like well no she's saying what you
said wasn't correct yes right and what a
lot of people had questions about so
look just to kind of wrap this up so in
conclusion we have new coveted findings
young men dying while gaming yes proof
of censoring a Surgeon General how does
this all come together
foreign
[Music]
actress Angela Lansbury passed away at
the age yeah 96. wow but she went on
doing it and she I she did love GTA 5
I'm just saying yep another one Gone Too
Soon 96 years old look unprotected sex
and Fentanyl as well don't game have
unprotected sex and use enough fentanyl
to kill an elephant which is still very
little she is very cocky on the gaming
too Murder She gloats oh that's a
terrible screen name bad handle don't do
that well look share the show thank you
for hanging out with us here on YouTube
we're gonna go behind the paywall and
have a more candid conversation about
some of the topics because if we do it
here we're just gonna absolutely get
kicked off and Steven's gonna run to the
restroom so yes I am piss off YouTube
thank you
foreign
[Music]